[Applause]
really nice so thank you so much for
joining man
because I was yeah so but yeah you see
it thank you for having me I'm super
excited and I'm I'm gutted that I that
I'm not not there I mean I can see yeah
you miss yourself on the crew and uh we
were already kind of uh starting to plan
the trip all by myself yeah yeah you
know
unfortunate but no it looks it looks
great it sounds like it's overflowing
with the attendees
yeah but thanks for not bringing Kobe
with you as well
[Laughter]
you're welcome you're welcome oh awesome
awesome so I would like to start this
round everybody is just giving a short
introduction about what they do like
what the background and like natural
language processing and generous also
what the interest is also where people
stand so uh let's start let's start with
remote like Alessandro so what's your
tell us a little bit about yourself like
uh one minute and what what what's your
yeah where you stand what natural
language processing
artificial in general right yeah sounds
good sounds good yeah so hello everybody
uh my name is Alejandro
um uh a currently director of uh
engineering applied science product at
uh zalando which is a European retailer
I'm also the chief scientist at the age
of practical AI which is an organization
that contributes to public policy as
well as uh uh you know open source and
General open projects for the
responsible development deployment of
machine learning systems and also
contribute to other initiatives through
the ACM
Nation as well as many of the pi datas
that uh Alexander actually organizes and
uh yeah in terms of where I stand in the
NLP side so
um uh throughout my career I've been
working on basically like uh
infrastructure for machine learning uh
but uh at one point in one of my
previous lives I was working on on
Regulatory Compliance automation uh
basically uh semi-structured text
extraction and that's actually where I
came across uh through the Spacey team
uh you know in essence Grace a great uh
framework uh and then delve into the
world of NLP since then I mean I think
we've seen kind of like now the hype and
the growth of llms and specifically to
the question of where I stand
um yeah I mean I would describe myself
as a skeptically excited right
because uh there's definitely some some
really good opportunities but maybe not
what we're hearing mostly kind of on
Twitter and uh yeah in just like uh that
sort of Doomsday narrative but certainly
seeing some really interesting use cases
and hopefully today we can dive into
some of them uh yeah
right thank you very much so uh Michael
you're a professor at a university here
this is your basically I'm pretty much
living in the first place yes
so yeah tell us about yourself yeah um
I'm here since 2008
um and Department of computer science
before then I was a professor at
University of California in Davis
California and I'm originally a database
person uh they moved to data mining
scientific data management then we were
interested in text extracting data
scientific data from text in particular
Geographic and temporal information so
something like name entities and in this
case and we move more and more into text
analytics and I'm now working in that
area for more now I would say at least
10 years no
um and all variety
um traditional NLP
um but in particular I would say I'm
very much devoted to Applications so I
have no project in computer science all
my projects are outside computer science
and it's in the league domain it's in
the medical domain it's with economics
so all over the place where they have a
lot of text and I think especially legal
domain and finance domain for example
economics it's quite interesting and
challenging here in this case and and
from that point I can say most of the
projects I've seen so far off the shelf
language models and tools they don't
work in these areas right so there's a
lot of stuff to that where you have to
do a fine-tuning adjusting getting
proper evaluation metrics and and so on
um but it's exciting but I personally
also find it frustrating because for me
it's hard to keep an overview so I'm
studying half an hour a day on LinkedIn
and basically following some people to
see what's going on and that's a
frustrating thing for me from an
academic side right that you are not
aware of where you are if you ever
considered a large language model
reading the papers
no I think like who feels like there's
so much new stuff like out every day
which is amazing but you can never
basically follow or even try it out just
raise your hand or things like that you
see like everybody yeah many people in
this room feel so we feel the same so
Alina yeah so hi everybody my name is
happy to be here I'm uh my educational
background is in a computational
Linguistics so I have a master's degree
from the University of tibian and I've
been working as a computational linguist
in uh translation and in automotive
industry so I've been working uh for
five years at cerence which is a
conversational AI company in the
automotive domain we're developing
speech assistance for cars
motorcycles and other applications in
Billy domain and I'm in text-to-speech
team working on text normalization
language identification problems and in
Academia I had projects also in text
classification and an average reference
resolution
so
um yeah I today I would be sharing my uh
view on how it would go how it would
work in production the llms and there I
stand with illness so the tools that you
have it depends on your requirements and
what you would like to achieve so llm is
not the only answer to the solutions
because we have like several people on
our team right and there's a small town
here to begin that has like the highest
number of explosion members per capita
let's see I mean
I mean so in all the unit slides in the
opening
What's Happening Here what's happening
in the South and the weather is better
anyway
um yeah so we we collected some
questions from uh from upfront and I
would like to uh start with Enos because
like India you've always been supporter
for open source and at the time when
there was like Hey cloud services models
yeah you just throw text at the models
you've never seen then you always say no
this is not the future Stacy is open
source so yeah it has half elements and
it changed anything
um well I mean one of the like yes and
one below mostly
yeah you've always had to if you think
commercially there has to be you like
people have this idea of like oh let's
look away or I'll go with them says lock
away our models and of course that can't
um you know really win because all the
work happens in Academia in the Commons
and it's always public but I think one
of the reasons I think cloud apis
um can you know only get us so far is
that doing the predictions is very
rarely the end of what you're doing like
it's usually like one part of your
system and you want to do more with
those predictions and you know you want
to load them back into some structured
format compute with them
um do stuff with them and so
um you know it's very limiting like you
know having a rest API and then trying
to translate that to Something in Python
um can be quite limited
um and of course there are also other
questions around data privacy sending
stuff to an API
um you also don't know what's behind
that like you know to say you need to be
a control of your data and that's why
it's never been yeah
with somebody else you need to program
with the model as well like it's the
part of the system and so I think it's
the same now sure you have scaling
effects of like these very large models
and um it's yeah it's not economical to
run that yourself but I do think that's
yeah
if you think it can do anything in
another way it's not working for their
domain yeah
tomorrow
because you don't control the model so
it's uh yeah so Alexander so um art L
M's dominating zelando already or
[Music]
yeah I mean I think I think
um
I think my my perspective would be
basically echoing uh what Ines just said
that
um it's only dominating
the like coffee chats right but when it
comes to the the the the actual
production
uh this is where
um I I do want to bring kind of like
like an interesting uh two-faced uh
perspective on this so on one is
basically some of the applications of
llms uh in salando which I think uh
people here will find quite interesting
but also the second part which is
um what llms have actually changed
generally uh including also in Sarandon
I think uh uh as in as pointed out I
think what it has changed is in a way it
has accelerated the discourse uh on
basically the questions around best
practices for mlops uh for complex
machine learning models right how do you
approach basically uh serving uh these
models in an efficient manner but also
how do you introduce uh from an
architectural perspective ways of
managing these models uh in actual real
life applications including things like
data quality including things like
um uh you know monitoring as well as
basically understanding what are kind of
like undesired or
um yeah like unintended effects of of
putting it out there and what I have
been seeing is that llms have uh kind of
like taken uh the World by storm more in
the prototyping space right like
actually trying to get an idea fast and
especially to get an idea fast in the
machine learning side right people are
actually building like even I don't know
sentiment classifiers by providing some
like prompts that would get you at least
to get something out quite fast but the
challenge when it comes to lens is to
get to that to get from that 90 to the
hundred percent and I think especially
in uh large organizations and
um large user bases you can't just put
in production on 90 right because that
10 percent may end up with impact uh to
both the organization the brand Etc but
you just you know cannot afford and I
think that is the uncertainty that we
still haven't been able to address and
for that first first point in terms of
like what are some use cases so I think
the most recent one that was actually
you know actually published was this
fashion assistant right it's like I'll
tell you what I like to wear recommend
me some clothes
um but I think yeah right now the the
current challenges that last 10 percent
uh that has always has been really very
interesting thing but I mean I think in
the operations of LMS there's a lot that
we can talk about but I'll just pause
there yeah
yeah I think that's a pretty interesting
take you say it's the prototyping stuff
because there's also like a lot of stuff
going on
music with AI which addresses the same
thing and just yesterday there was a
really nice article and uh MIT
technology reviewed is that actually
like for a new Star Wars series
um the producer considered hey I want
Hans Zimmer so uh they asked the startup
can you do a Hans simmer soundtrack and
when they listen to it or they say yeah
that's sounds like let's go but um it's
just like a seven of ten and if you hire
Hans Zimmer for a soundtrack you hire
him for 10 and not the seven and I think
that was a very good another
take on what a lot of models can do but
also that's challenging
but actually this was like he brought up
like a point that also
play Maybe didn't make so well
um of like hey what delivers the value
it's like hey and you know what really
matters like hey the fashion assistant
Orlando is cool like I don't know maybe
I would use it for fun maybe they drive
some more
pair of shoes but like what really you
know if that if that is five percent
more accurate does Orlando make more
money probably not
um but if the recommendation system or
like some more old like you know some of
the bread and butter is like one percent
more accurate that's like 10 million
plus right like that's that's the sort
of at least which I get from companies
yeah yeah no I I completely agree and
and I think that the interesting thing
is is actually when um we start looking
at use cases of of llms not as the
chatbots themselves but as components uh
cogs in the system and I think this is
the the second part I mean I think we
can dive into it but the other part that
actually like LMS are opening up in the
discourse of operationalization is
basically
um
um let's call it uh data Centric
architectures for for machine learning
models right where you have actually
multiple nodes in your you know machine
Learning System where you know a lot a
lot of the mmm world is starting to call
it basically like agent chain
architectures but beyond the LMS you
have just basically ml systems right
which just the llms is one small
component I think it's what you're
saying in as that like the real value is
is the whole Machinery not just the Cog
so yeah absolutely absolutely agree yeah
yeah but also like we have challenges
for the name Michael got like when we
talked before I said hey how how can you
keep up with that in your studies I mean
that's there's always so many new things
also like the technology like technology
can you say hey please put this element
on your laptop GTP API is probably not
good enough so so um that's a challenge
any solutions or is it something we
should ideas how can a community help
for a thing or is it basically someone
interesting a part of the direction is
really this this fine tuning the
different types of fine tuning you have
for example this uh Laura Lauren
approximation and and QR quantization
models and these things I think this is
a cool Direction then in this case right
so yeah I don't think it makes much
sense to train larger and larger models
than in this case but to focus on how do
we reduce the size of this mold and keep
their the quality right it's like like a
knowledge destination in a very very
similar Direction in this case
um but also I have a much closer look at
the data and I think that's what
everybody seems to be missing they don't
look at the data right if you have poor
quality data
what do you expect then in
and when people spend more time looking
at the data and even many benchmarks
that are out there if you look at their
quality in terms of duplicates data
incomplete data and so on and so on and
then there are fine-tuning a model on
poor quality data true in reality I
think you also have poor quality data
but I think but I think it's time worse
spent on improving the quality curating
the data and then having a stable good
model then in this case so these are the
two areas where things still of stuff
can be done that on the data side and on
the optimization side not trading larger
models in this case and in particular I
am not a big fan of these
um yeah prompt engineering hype stuff at
the moment right so for those of you who
know Adventures these text adventures in
the 80s okay that's a really good one
this was some kind of prompting go left
yeah
Etc all right so it goes It goes in that
direction nobody can explain it quite in
in a way right it's all statistics
eventually uh but it's very hard to
teach okay if we have to do this in
school at University how do you teach
about prompting right with these 50
pages and tears and other good three
prompts and so there's no real
scientific approach to this I I think it
actually is there
statistics I think definitely send
people the Linguistics class because
for example if you have to explain if
you if you chase this wording a little
bit you get a completely different yeah
because one of 175 billion parameters
you know another yeah that's not
something satisfying to me at least yeah
it might work but it's not satisfying
from the side yeah so like tomorrow
tomorrow actually I'm a full day
workshop with lawyers and I ask them
just like of course because like I like
to use judge GDP just for inspiration
anyway just throw me some ideas and then
I said IO as a coach what should I ask
like lawyers about L M's and then lnfs
was actually like a master of for
legitive something because it was
Lawyers it was very close so it was not
large language models for example so you
change a bit and so is prompting
actually a real thing or is that just
like people made up yeah you need to
learn from things they're like a logic
or is it more trying error on people
yeah
like some techniques one thing ads
actually people Predator Amsterdam my
colleague gave a talk online you can
find it online and I think sooner than
this like with you from tournaments
there's like you know the more empirical
like he I think developed like some
um you know something similar to like an
email rating for
um yeah comparing problems and you can
do something like that but then again
that's too close to oh eat your
vegetables look at your data that's not
stable if you can modify your model a
little bit
oh but that's work and then I have to
look at the data and it's like you know
I think people overestimate all sort of
work it takes it's maybe you know it
says oh but it's like honestly I mean
you're gonna spend more time on waiting
for BT to return the results given a
latency then you would like actually
just look at your data very cool because
also one of the first questions I
reached out to some experts and uh DBA
actually asked how do you think on
productionizing large models uh for like
smaller smaller applications but I think
yeah use proper data
you know if you're only using them for
development time that also changes a lot
of the calculations so if you can find
an approach there where you use it use
them for development to create better
data to
um you know like just generate stuff you
could work with and not in production if
you could find something much smaller
then you also have a few of the problems
you have if you're thinking of like oh
how do I productionize a billion
parameter model Yes actually you then
probably an API provider Does it Better
I mean you work at a company they you
have like expert like already fine-tuned
working systems like for like special
guys
motorcycles actually it's coming here
that's cool so yeah but what are the
showers and oh my god let's change this
look it's clear the shift or no Let's
ignore that because we can never put it
in the hardware anywhere so what is the
situation uh okay yeah so uh uh
basically uh for me like in uh the NLP
evolution is like happening like when I
basically studied
uh to me llm is rather one of the tools
it's not uh V to to use uh because it
really depends on on the problem that
you're trying to solve for example the
uh what Ian is presented in the slide to
identify five million dollar in the text
that it's a an amount of uh yeah of
money apparently you might not need like
a very complex model for that you can go
for rules it's more controllable and
it's cheap and you know for your
particular domain uh what you encounter
in in your data and that's one approach
it doesn't mean that if there is
something cooler that this should be
disregarded not necessarily so
um what uh I think still a big advantage
of llm is that you can experiment fast
you can prototype fast uh that we can't
neglect that and that that is helping
also for product teams who might not
have a very in-depth knowledge of uh
yeah uh coding deep learning and uh yeah
or all the technical like coding skills
that you need uh you can uh build
something uh based on the available apis
or models and then uh just prove your
hypothesis is what you are trying to
build is it worth uh and uh to get
feedback faster uh with like no code
almost you can also yeah generate the
code for you using the same model so uh
that's a big thing and also the
multilingual support of the models
that's uh uh also a big Advantage
because uh uh in computational
linguistics everything works for uh
English very good and when we switch to
uh close to your language history
English the better it works exactly yeah
and then you switch to Korean Basque
whatever so lower Source languages or
languages that are historically didn't
have that much amount of data simply
because not that many peoples
speak that language and not in many
data sources are available
where you are working on a very specific
task that is maybe a niche task in the
NLP field for example my area was uh
MultiLing multilingual support in
text-to-speech meaning that German voice
can also pronounce French city names
correctly or Italian
person names companies things like that
where do you find the data for that and
to uh really compile it from scratch
that's a lot of manual work and you can
already gain at least some rather
Baseline with just uh yeah trying out a
few promising if it fits your task and
to have uh to build your Baseline and
prove your idea quite quite fast so for
that I would like to yeah uh yeah say
that it's a good thing about prompties
you can experiment and and see what you
get out of it
uh obviously the challenges
uh the restrictions that you have not in
uh because of the llm itself but what
are the requirements for for your
product the ram requiring CPU requests
it's uh it's still there it's just one
of the dependencies that you are adding
or you are substituting something in
your stack so uh and in the embedded
Technologies for example for automotive
industry uh you not you're not always
having a connection to the cloud
especially if you are like in the German
tunnel
and there are very
um yeah uh very strict limitations on
what you uh should put in the car and uh
because it's not we might have a perfect
dialogue but if navigation system
doesn't couldn't work because the
latency is to to high I that that's not
uh not good so it's it's still of course
um the industry uh like the the
customers the uh conversational AI
companies are experimenting a lot with
llms I cannot speak of course for every
branch and domain that I'm speaking
about what I know uh and um yeah trying
to fine-tune uh downsize the model for a
specific task
Etc so that's happening and uh but it
doesn't mean that the technology that
you had before you really have to get
rid of it it depends on what you're
trying to improve which methods don't
work for your task good enough and uh
yeah then you
decide which approach is better and I
like The Benchmark that you've shown
today that yeah it doesn't mean
necessarily really that a new new model
is uh yeah greatest it's just yeah even
I mean some people might say well but
that's all the amount of time they can
just make it bigger and bigger and I'm
like well sure I mean I'm sure
eventually like yes we can have a model
we both parameters they can beat like
the Cardinal scores from 2003 of course
but at the same time if you can do that
we can also make even better smaller
models like you know why why would that
not be true so that's kind of the
yeah
the logic there and but also I think for
the cars I just like like I don't know
because I'm interested like is it just
like oh people
talking to the car and telling it to
like I'll turn here do that or yeah yeah
and tell me the joke
but no it's small
kids also this misconception I mean
there is sort of a coded language
already there like people are fine with
learning like oh I have to say turn left
and not like oh some flowery long-winded
description of turning left and it's
like that's so useful it's like turn
left yeah and again that's like oh do
you even need fancy deep learning models
for that I mean we had like speech
recognition yeah like the natural
language understanding really remains
yeah yeah big challenge yeah uh and uh
speaking about that like uh the results
should be reproducible and stable like
if you say the same command your ex you
expect that the output should be yeah we
need of course some variability uh in
the model response but it still should
matter should match the intent and uh
the problem is also if there is a whole
variety of answers
how do you do regression testing how do
you evaluate the model performance
because if we need to uh have more even
more human effort to validate a llam uh
create creativity that's too too much
yeah that brings us to the next question
and I at least I'm going to try to speak
a little I hope it's okay for me let's
speak a bit louder so we got some
feedback and I can't I have no clue how
to turn up the volume
right that's fine yeah thank you so
production and like they're so good how
can it some feed thoughts on upper Ops
of large language models and also what
does the industry actually need
yeah sorry I'm still thirsty for myself
I already had a video but it didn't
really help
friends
so yeah
yeah no I was just saying I I would love
one as well but I can't
yeah oh thank you thank you thank you
very much
but yeah so so on the operation side I
mean I I think already yeah like uh uh
this discussion uh talked about a couple
of uh really interesting points so it
talked about uh reproducibility uh it
talked about uh considerations of um
yeah I guess more embedded type
deployments uh on reliable networks
um but I think other items that are
worth also considering that I think uh
you know from my perspective
um are are we coming now interestingly
enough significantly uh much more
um highly discussed or commonly
discussed
compared to before is the topic of
security security in machine learning
itself so one thing to mention is that I
mean the field of machine learning
applied into security I mean it's
something that that you know is present
since you know the 70s right like we
always start that University course
where they tell you how to use a base
classifier for uh you know spam not spam
right
um so so ultimately when it comes to
applying machine learning into in cyber
security that's something that has been
uh quite quite uh present but the the
topic itself of um security for machine
learning is something that right now is
not is is becoming even more critical
right is how
um what are some of the the potential
vulnerability uh risks when it comes to
production machine Learning Systems uh
what are some considerations and best
practices as you know the different
stages of the machine learning life
cycle all the way from the data to the
model training to the model deployment
to the monitoring to the metadata
management and there has been actually
some really interesting developments
that have discovered that I mean indeed
every single stage of the machine
learning life cycle is susceptible to
you know vulnerabilities but also that
there has uh there are some really
interesting
gaps within the ecosystem I mean just
the fact that uh you know practitioners
us we love pickles right we love uh our
pickles I mean maybe maybe a shovel has
explained pickle in one sentence to
people well I want I want maybe I show
up
hands in the machine learning
oh yeah hello
all right a lot okay well so so
basically uh uh pickles are just uh
binary exports of trained machine
learning models and I mean I think
that's probably kind of like a
compliment it's actually just like
python binary dumps right in a in a
non-safe format and uh uh ultimately
this has been kind of like now an area
of uh discussion of how do you kind of
like uh introduce security and things
like this right but there's also
challenges when it comes to things like
uh you know the data itself uh there's
elements of like data poisoning there's
elements of uh you know uh um malicious
kind of modification of the of the
artifacts themselves and it's also kind
of uh the the the the adversarial attack
family of of uh of vulnerabilities which
is basically like the challenge of
either reverse engineering your models
or exploiting their their their their
capabilities and I think this is
something that we're gonna start seeing
more and more just because going back to
llms we are starting to
to basically
um
forget what we are told in the 101 of
software right which is basically don't
let strangers in the internet just send
random commands to your computer with
pseudo access pretty much right
um and and the reason why I'm mentioning
this is because going back to the
architectures that we're now starting to
see in machine learning systems like
this uh agent chain architectures where
you basically have let's connect this
this llm that interacts with my XYZ API
right and oh look how cool I ask this
llm to book my trip in XYZ website for
booking trips right and then oh wow this
was great it saved me you know one
percent of the time that I would have
saved if I had gone and done done it
myself but I do it because you know it's
it's cool and it's Tech right but I
think this is the sort of things that
you know we do have to be aware and I'm
giving a very sort of like you know
clear obvious example is like yes don't
connect your your bank account with an
llm of course but I think uh when it
when it becomes to to production systems
it's more much more nuanced right
because it's ultimately multiple hubs of
different components that have different
levels of of capability and interactions
with different systems that in the chain
itself you yourself may not have full
awareness of what could be a corner case
that that could open up a new
vulnerability right so I think again
llms are providing much more
um you know intuitive use cases but we
are seeing this going back to that
example where the llm is one specific
small piece of the Cog or even to what
what is now being discussed basically
saying hey I don't want I use this llm
for prototyping and now I want to just
train this proper uh entity extraction
model right on the data that was that
was generated
um but I want to still connect it into
my entire sort of system now you have to
take into consideration not just the
security of your machine learning model
but the security of your machine
Learning System
um but yeah so I mean I think there's
there's other things when it comes to
the the operationalization
um but I wanted to talk about security
specifically so but yeah I'll just uh
pause there to see yeah what are the
thoughts they are with the panel yeah
one of our thoughts like LMS cyber
security
European production acts well I mean I
think just your data privacy I mean
that's just something that's always good
so actually it is
a distinction to make because it's they
always says
actually it's the data that needs to
protected
Security application of data in AI
models even before like even
between
anything it's like yeah it's just like
an innocent Network yeah right yeah well
I mean I think it's nice to actually see
that people that data privacy being
talked about a lot more like this though
some people have to say oh yeah it's
just
data protection stuff but it's actually
like a lot of companies are like well no
we can't I think we should think there's
many interesting approaches or like
saying hey and AI is also like it's a
zipper of the internet yes one I think
you said yeah it's also a data storage
it's not like yeah it's yeah
I'm like um you know well at that day I
lost for it but I don't want the
landlord to take like all the info they
have about me from like I don't know my
decade of ordering and then okay
I did not read the terms and conditions
all the terms and conditions yeah all
your data belongs to to us now but I'm
just my soul
yeah uh all for some new shoes yes of
course yeah so one thing to to mention
as well that is interesting is this
point on data privacy just because uh
data privacy itself it's it's something
that for organizations it's a big
challenge because it's not a static
um risk right and uh ultimately this
risk
um basically what what what it entails
is that often you may have data sets
that that in themselves may be
considered private but improvements in
technology may actually
result in those same data sets
um potentially exposing
um many more insights and potentially
even personal Insight personal insights
given the the ability to to to extract
insights out of kind of like the the the
the larger area so I think um what uh
the European
ecosystem has done the regulatory
ecosystem has done is some really
interesting Explorations into this
element of uh the continuously shifting
um a a dial of of of of privacy of this
relationship between privacy and data
right as as sorry privacy and and and
and data and technology advancements uh
because as we see as we see more kind of
like you know capabilities within I mean
whether it's llms or just other machine
learning models
um we are actually seeing even more uh
potential risks in data sets that before
we were comfortable giving but now we're
realizing that it's being used uh let's
say even in some cases against us right
uh and particularly we see this a lot in
the ad Tech uh type type areas
um so so I totally agree that that
privacy is super key and that Europe is
actually doing some really interesting
uh Explorations on on that as well
right so I think it's not only privacy
in this case and I think I know a couple
of companies they deal with the Privacy
issue by massaging the data by creating
the data if they take medical data and
they want to get something out of that
they're doing anonymization so
beforehand right it's not after the
effect pre-processing measures here in
this case so it goes again yeah it will
take care of your data right so it's no
wonder that you have private data in
your model if you didn't take care of
the data that went in there so there's
definitely one point but privacy I don't
think that privacy is such a big issue
but more and more often from a consumer
perspective where now these lmms are
used in the context of chatbot it's
reliability for example we know all
about this hallucination and so on oh
yeah and if you look closely at the EU
area for example that's that's the main
entrances here as well right the right
reliability the quality the quality of
the results there in this case and and
for me this is basically uh something
well how would you how do you want to
deal with it how do you want to show
that you know um it's high quality then
in this case you can only have a
benchmark as soon as you do have some
fine tuning or so you lose again in this
case and I think this is a tremendously
Big Challenge if you want to convince
lawmakers in the EU to make better use
of these models in a variety of services
that you also come up with
infrastructures to properly evaluate
these L M's in the context of particular
Services I think this is a big challenge
if you really are aiming at using lmms
at a larger scale and not at just
companies and not just for jet GPT on
how how high is the Eiffel Tower and
something like that because I think
ironically I actually have the feeling
that like going forward in a lot of
commercial applications they'll actually
like just put humans in front of the
output again I mean you can't understand
that online service but if they're you
know they're doing all of these all
fancy machine learning work and then at
the end there's like a human looking at
all the outputs so that legal there's
someone to blame and that like oh it
fits into our Frameworks and like and I
don't know at least until we have a
better solution for it because there is
something yeah right yeah as you said
the output and you must do something
this is output yes
for communities to train their own
models like to curate their own models
so the models actually literacy speak
their language and and uh and and
reflect what the community is about
because currently we have these large
models that basically suck all the
internet and but we of course see of
course especially if something smaller
it's like smaller Community it's not
reflected at all it's always like that
yeah it's the common ground and that's
dominated by larger populations or like
populations that just produce more text
than others so
um yeah so um
the fun question actually from Swedish
and an important question so when can I
get that awesome
[Laughter]
it's funny you you're really not the
first person to ask there's someone
asking on
um Twitter I got so many questions
um we've been we've been thinking about
it okay so this was this was just
watching today yeah this was designed by
um like an awesome designer who's
working student Helena working for us
and the instructions were like oh hey we
want something custom like it even has
the display see visualizer here it's
basically like it's very custom and I
said I really want to share that that
can work in Black because all these like
company shirts they're always in colors
and I don't wear colors I'm like I would
love to wear a shirt that's how this
came about it's only for the team at the
moment but there's a lot of things this
thing really is a lot of demand and we
have been joking about like oh what if
like I don't know whether scrap all of
this AI development and like commercial
leg software thing maybe our future
revenues is going to be in t-shirts
sign me up sign me up
yeah so uh yeah so um
so what's uh what's the future of
elements is it just a hike I mean you're
probably where would you we stand in the
car probably at the vegan it's going to
be go really long soon or
um is
I think it's more of a tool like no
other yeah like any other tour and we
have to learn how to do that and then I
think there are like a lot of societal
questions and of course like hey I'm
using Esports in like a bay like it is
the technology
actually a sold a computer on eBay and I
thought oh don't sell it on eBay because
they always like a custom like the buyer
always wins so it was just it was a bear
book there was no hard drive there was
an operating system that was around and
the person what is sent me a screenshot
no sorry I cannot login into my
Microsoft account I said no computer
obviously works and chat gpp like gave
me like uh and I hate running stuff like
that but I said hey fun right something
friendly you know they said oh I'm so
sorry
and also and of course I said oh yeah
it's a Microsoft demand he used to use
an apple.me address and I put all the
information because I knew eventually
somebody from eBay support will read it
and guess what I want it's amazing uh
yeah anyway
um yeah so you can help it can be really
useful like
wedding vowels
until we noticed that the way it
involves for everybody yes
no he's still very happily married
yeah so uh so aren't any other like
Trends what about like because we always
say chat GTP that's
a battlefield that's like there's a
model of Everything Is there is there
anything we could distinguish between
them or is it just like all the same
well you should have the task right yeah
so for example I currently a lot of
students doing their uh final thesis and
I cannot change a model every week right
they can stop using Falcon use llama you
know right okay because it doesn't
matter that much I mean it's methodology
I think in this case you see the
description of the data what goes in
there I think it's surrounding any
particular task why are you using this
for if once you have the task I think
then the model doesn't matter that much
with the use okay or any of these large
models it's just fine concentrate on the
task and I think this is a big
difference or between models but it is
but also again it depends
Academia you follow like what's
happening and then you see like all the
papers and it can be hard to like you
know really distinguishing what matters
and what doesn't it actually often the
approaches well you step back and wait a
bit
you have to wait until stuff catches on
like you cannot tell whether something
is going to be a thing and if the
community is going to standardize on
something until you wait or like for
example now if we're looking at like you
know the more old school Transformer
architectures and Transformer weights
that people now getting more LMS like
birth or birth or whatever they were
like hundreds thousands of them but now
the community has largely standardized
on a handful it's like bird for Birds
four like this like a few and if you
wait long enough you're like okay those
are the ones so it's like we kind of
implemented a mini Library so we had
like better building blocks for
Transformer architectures and paper
which it's called QA Transformers Maybe
project and we were like well we don't
have to implement everything like which
one school is a handful grade done and I
understand by just waiting I think what
we need are infrastructures that help up
to evaluate these language models more
efficiently if you look at Frameworks
like help the holistic evaluation of
language models from Stanford right if
you if I ask you well what metric would
you pick for example to evaluate
language model well it depends on the
task right even summarization there are
gazillions of of different
but dozens of different metrics in this
case and if you look at the paper like
this like Helm for example where they
have 52 or 54 metrics just for llms
right it's not just prediction and
recall some a precision and recall there
are so many different things and I think
one better has to know about these
things in particular right it seems to
me that people are setting up some
infrastructure and they have no clue
about how to evaluate how to how what
metric to pick here in this case so I
think there's also a little bit of
Education still needs to be done here in
this case and unfortunately there are a
whole bunch of good YouTube videos on
there right so you don't have to go to
the university I have to say
so you're still welcome of course
foreign
[Laughter]
but you know these things as well right
it's not just hacking for me it seems
hacking most of the time oh it works
great
in this in this case but the solid
engineering approach a lot of
engineering is missing I think
in case what do you do how do you
evaluate how do you choose a metric in
this case how do you compare models for
example how do you choose efficiency
versus performance in this case so as it
has really changed your teaching and
saying hey
um well I'm in bad situation in the
process of playing a new class where I
have to cover want to cover many of
these things so good luck
um if you consider the YouTube playlists
program in Pakistan the same my brother
spent the time with the students in the
room hey let's discuss problems because
I don't really need to yeah
there's good content uh you can go there
because I always lost track and class so
I think you never can basically it is
but then better has come up right for
example what Frameworks to use do you
have in place do you use links and oh
what you what do you use here in this
case right there are so there are so
many Frameworks in this case so to start
with in this case even I do not know
what to pick here in this case well like
something like pie chart I was like yes
God right so it's it's like this but I
think we are not like striving to find
like the ideas we we never will find it
it's really Case by case uh uh like uh
for example yeah for me it's relevant
how many languages the model support uh
because if
um yeah for example in
text-to-speech team we have 65 language
support so and not all the popular
models have all that coverage uh and uh
yeah the latency can be hosted uh or is
it uh yeah we need to uh send API calls
things like that it's just depending on
what are your technical requirements the
content is not
clear what is the model trained on Which
languages sort of data sets this is very
often blurry or not available as well
right I think you'll be back at like
reasoning about stuff looking at the
data and I think a lot of what you
describe is stuff like trying to solve
things with tech that you should solve
with reasoning and like thinking and
that's like I think that's a general
pattern in our society it's like oh
that's so cool with it let's solve fun
change let's solve poverty with
technology it's like you know it doesn't
work like that
yeah cool so um any
final comments
and yeah
yeah
duplication
form but it's like if you put it on the
website it's like attracts too many
people who try to scam there's always a
large company it's really you have to I
mean it's yeah
lying around right so they're like oh
I'm a researcher and I'm like no yeah
[Laughter]
what's like any final thoughts on about
language models to share with the crowd
um yes I mean I think final thoughts
maybe going back to the trends I think
uh one of the trends perhaps that maybe
I can think of
or that I can hope for is
um yeah probably going away from
chatbots uh is is one uh because I mean
I think if you remember back in 2012
there was also a huge hype on chatbots
and that didn't fly I mean that reminded
me of the of the hype on drones and also
the high Pawn I mean there's many Hypes
right uh but yeah so I think I think
there's a lot of potential uh with with
uh you know llmsr technology but um yeah
I mean I think it's looking beyond the
obvious kind of like uh here is the llm
in front of you talk with it
um and I think another Trend that is
interesting is
um basically it was slightly touched
upon but the use of Transformers in
different areas I mean right now an area
that is exploding is forecasting
um so you know demand forecasting
um you know anything to do with uh you
know regression based uh well that would
otherwise be approached with
regression-based models like you know
sorry arima or or the most traditional
ones I think now we're starting to see
some Innovations and Transformer based
architectures for that
um and I think yeah other other fields
where we're starting to see Transformers
being kind of like brought into
um so yeah so it's basically like the
imagenet moment for different areas
um yeah I mean it feels dated now the
images
which is pretty funny
um so yeah so so so no other thoughts I
mean maybe maybe another
um yeah Shameless plug
um yeah I mean at salando we're always
looking for bright Minds
yeah yes check it out
right I don't think it's time to sell
shoes
or check out the the fashion assistant I
guess get some issues
bye
I find the exciting time yeah um I'm
glad that so many people are interested
in this that this technology is easily
accessible yeah to people who know
little program I think that's cool right
if you compare it with 10 years ago how
difficult it was to use machine learning
at all so I think this is very cool it
gives you some ideas and hopefully
especially young people it motivates
them to
do something good with the technology
and I think that's important thing I
don't look at the business but also try
to do something good with no I think
it's an excellent point right how
accessible like even the models are like
now like billions and millions of
dollars to create yes in there and then
you see what Google did with it with
this protein folding things and so how
it advances field and I think in that
area we can gain a lot in particular
everything that has to do with public
health is poverty and so that's all the
thing about how to do this and not just
sell stuff to people and convince people
to buy something
it says
one of the biggest problems in our times
is that the smartest people actually are
working on selling like optimizing ads
on the internet like and that's that's
sad very true
um yeah so let me know what are your
thoughts
um well I'm curious and like next
development also what uh like uh in
which creative ways the technology will
be used and hopeful hopefully be ethical
and secure security aspect won't be
forgotten uh I think it also opens
access to people who were maybe yeah not
interested in technology now it's
becoming more accessible to them
um and that's a good thing so I'm
curious what the future brings but there
are also All Tech that is still still
functional
um
yeah thank you all so much for joining
get well soon thank you so much thank
you for having me thank you for having
me and still got it I couldn't be there
but thank you for having me as always
the next
all right
this brings us to the next Point that's
lightning talks so bye-bye